the more people that tell you a lie does
that ever make it a truth what about if
that lie was on credible websites would
that make it more likely to be true so
today we're going to talk about
carbohydrate lies because if you look up
symptoms and signs of carbohydrate
deficiencies you're going to find
information that not only is untrue but
it's the complete opposite of what
really happens you'll be told that our
brain and our muscles need carbohydrate
to function you'll be told that glucose
is the primary fuel that our body
prefers and that when you start cutting
out one of the major food groups
carbohydrates all sorts of very bad
things happen like craving junk food
like crazy and craved carbohydrates
because you're cutting out carbohydrates
you'll be hungry all the time which is
not good if you're trying to lose weight
you'll start experiencing brain fog and
fatigue because you're going to starve
your brain of its fuel that it really
needs you may experience mood swings
irritability
hypoglycemic symptoms when you exercise
your performance will be terrible
because you're depleting all of the
glycogen the stored sugar in your
muscles and unless you start consuming
things like Gatorade or sugar boy you're
going to be tired and the more that you
start cutting out these carbs the more
constipation because you're cutting out
fiber and of course you might experience
headaches and bad breath it's called
keto breath and yes you may experience
some temporary weight loss but you're
really just losing water weight and with
water weight loss comes a loss of
electrolytes and you may start
experiencing palpitations and
arrhythmias and atrial fibrillation that
could lead to Strokes having a
carbohydrate deficiency apparently it's
very dangerous in fact you may even end
up with a disease to talk about the
disease being lactic acidosis right well
first of all that oh only will occur if
you're a type 1 diabetic and you don't
take your insulin lactic acidosis that
comes from ketoacidosis is not even
similar to being in ketosis okay there
are two different things completely
different one is pathogenic and one is
super healthy and then they might relate
to ketosis to starvation because if you
starve your body you go into ketosis and
because starvation is bad ketosis is bad
what about intermittent fasting that's
different than starvation starvation
occurs after you lose all your fat which
can take months okay and then you're
breaking down your muscles but fasting
is really different
when you do fasting for once you finally
are able to tap in to your own fact but
you'll never tap in the fat unless you
have a carbohydrate deficiency so let's
talk about the true benefits in a
carbohydrate deficiency which is the
opposite of what they say Okay number
one you're not going to have any more
Cravings okay number two you're going to
lose your appetite you're no longer
going to be hungry number three you're
going to have wonderful cognitive
improvements your brain is going to work
better next thing is your mood's going
to be better if you had depression if
you had anxiety now as far as your
performance for exercise
you're going to be able to tap into fat
fuel which is going to allow you to have
a better steady energy and your exercise
is going to be much much better it is
true that you will lose glycogen while
you're on a lower carbohydrate diet and
with a loss of glycogen comes a loss of
fluids okay and with that comes a loss
of electrolytes especially salt so if
you're deficient in salt your
performance with exercise is going to be
greatly diminished but all you have to
do is take more sea salt and take
electrolytes and any type of fatigue
problems or lack of performance will be
dramatically improved your brain is
going to work better you're going to
have less headaches and as far as bad
breath personally I have never had bad
breath going on the ketogenic diet I've
talked to tens of thousands of people
and it's very rare to have bad breath if
you're doing keto correctly now it is
true that if you do the dirty version of
Keto which basically is you're not
paying attention to the quality of food
so you know at a fast food place or
whatever yes you may have some bad
breath and when you initially adapt to
the ketogenic diet you may also have
some bad breath but it's so temporary as
soon as your body starts burning more
ketones and starts to utilize these
ketones more efficiently this is why the
tests that they use to measure ketones
from your breath and the urine are not
going to work once you really get into
keto adaptation so if you're new to keto
this is what you need to know you have
to bring the carbs way down to roughly
between 30 to 50 grams per day now let's
compare that to what's recommended by
all of these websites okay the amount of
carbohydrates that is normally
recommended by the majority of experts
is between now are you sitting for this
225 to 325 grams of carbohydrates every
single day that's more than 10 times the
amount than what you really need to get
into ketosis it's kind of like lowering
your carbs a little bit but not enough
to really tap into your fat so you are
going to feel crummy you are going to
have hypoglycemia you are going to have
a lot of problems so you must reduce the
carbs
way down to about 30 to 50 grams okay to
be able to have this all work and you
must also give it a little bit of time
usually between two to three days at the
very most but once your body converts
over wow you will experience benefits
that you've never experienced before any
carbohydrate that your brain requires
can be made from
non-carbohydrate sources okay and the
term for this is called gluco neo
genesis glucose meaning sugar Neo
meaning new genesis meaning the creation
of or making of something you're making
new sugar out of fat ketones or protein
you don't need carbs there's no such
thing as an essential carbohydrate but
there is an essential fatty acid in fact
there's really no study that shows or
proves that a carbohydrate deficiency
leads to anything bad at all in fact
it's just the opposite when you restrict
your carbohydrates all sorts of
wonderful things happen especially if
you do the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet now if you're new to keto
and you want to know how to do it
healthily I put that video up right here
check it out